l'effet de la vaccination et des mesures
de restriction ne se fait pas encore
sentir en témoigne ce flou
d'hospitalisation en indre-et-loire 50
personnes sont actuellement en soins de
réanimation et au chru de tours on
approche du nombre de patients recensés
au plus fort de la première vague l'an
dernier pour les équipes soignantes
c'est un véritable marathon chaque jour
nous vous proposons ce soir une
immersion dans le service réa de
l'hôpital trousseau reportage signé paul
boyer parmi la quinzaine de soignants
présents chaque jour des renforts issus
d'autres services de l'hôpital et des
jeunes fraîchement diplômés ont fait en
tant qu'étudiante infirmières dans la
première vague dont je me suis porté
volontaire en salle de réanimation
et quand des deux diplômés début juillet
j'ai commencé direct ici en réanimation
chirurgicale
donc j'ai commencé directement dans le
dur c'est de s'occuper de patients
qu'ovide des patients qui restent plus
longtemps soins comme philippe
un souci c'est que je suis asthmatique
de naissance donc je dirais vous avez
bon espoir pour la suite
les patients avec cette crise sont de
plus en plus lourd parce qu'il ya une
sélection des malades les plus sévères
donc la durée de séjour se compte en
semaines maintenant pour la plupart en
tout cas pour les patients qu'aux vide
et aussi pour une partie des patients
non coville en tout cas en réanimation
dans ce service
huit sont dédiés au co vide dans les six
autres des patients en état critique
probablement une partie de ses patients
qui sont des patients qui n'ont pas été
pris en charge pendant la première ou la
deuxième vague pour plein de raisons
différentes et qui aujourd'hui se
retrouvent avec des pathologies qui
finalement sont plus graves et les amène
peut-être plus volontiers en réanimation
une charge de travail lourdes
la fatigue se fait ressentir pour les
soignants leur vigilance est constante
pour éviter les contaminations pour 40
degrés ressentis cela blues charlotte
lunettes
un vrai parcours du combattant pour
rentrer dans les chambres et éviter les
contaminations en sortant on passe dans
la partie extérieure
nous avons un couloir extérieur qui nous
permet de nous mettre propre de notre
côté et donc quand nous revenons ici
nous sommes propres et on a pas de
risque de croiser des gens qui peuvent
être contaminées en service réanimation
qu'ovide aucune visite n'est possible
dans les chambres une première aussi
pour ses soignants pas pouvoir faire
entrer les familles
famille n'osera pas leur papa c'était
très difficile
après il ya des téléphones dans les
champs pour qu'on essaie aussi de passer
les patients leurs familles quand
c'était possible pour l'aider c'était un
peu d'autant plus dur que les patients
ici sont de plus en plus jeunes ce qui
inquiète les services de réanimation